et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Olivier du socle bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec ce ministre du Travail du
plan emploi et de l'insertion on va
évidemment parler de la loi sur le plein
emploi qui arrive au Sénat cet
après-midi mais d'abord un mot de
l'actualité ce week-end ont eu lieu des
manifestation a eu lieu une
manifestation interdite pour Adama
Traoré à laquelle en participait des
parlementaires de la nuque de la France
insoumise des vers dont Eric Coquerel le
président de la commission des finances
de l'Assemblée au milieu de gens qui
chantent tout le monde déteste la police
est-ce que ça pose la question de son
maintien la tête de la commission des
finances le seul fait que vous soyez
obligé de formuler la question est une
réponse en soi c'est
incroyable et inacceptable parce qu'on
est parlementaire lorsqu'on a la chance
de porter une écharpe tricolore de
législateur de participer à une
manifestation interdite
interditeur
il faut savoir qui on est ce que l'on
veut parce qu'on fait la loi on respecte
la loi on respecte la loi on respecte
les décisions de la justice et de
l'administration et on ne s'affiche pas
dans une manifestation interdite qui
plus est une manifestation interdite qui
a un réalité manifestation
contre la police vous l'avez dit
manifester entouré de gens qui qui
scandent tout le monde déteste la police
est un scandale absolu c'est quelque
chose d'inacceptable c'est quelque chose
qui n'est pas à la hauteur d'un
parlementaire et la présidente de
l'Assemblée
je partage de qualificatif et pour vous
ne peut plus rester à la tête de la
commission des finances
qui décident de cela et ce n'est pas au
gouvernement de le dire mais président
de la commission des finances ou députés
c'est une fonction en soi qui impose de
respecter les décisions
pas seulement lui tous la présidence
c'est la question la responsabilité des
députés
la semaine dernière les députés de la
France insoumises ont demandé au Conseil
d'État d'annulation des sanctions qui
leur ont été infligées à l'Assemblée
pour leur comportement lors des débats
sur la réforme des retraites familles à
thomasport qui avait été exclu de
l'Assemblée parce qu'il s'est mis en
scène en ayant posé le pied sur un
ballon à votre effigie va-t-il panneau
prévient que son groupe se tournera vers
la justice européenne si nécessaire
c'est-à-dire si ces sanctions ne sont
pas annulées
ce sont des députés qui abîment
l'institution de l'Intérieur qui
nourrissent l'anti parlementarisme vous
avez évoqué le débat sur les retraites
j'étais en première ligne je les mené
vous avez un député qui a posé avec un
ballon à mon effigie il manque une
décapitation un autre qui m'a traité
d'assassin dans l'hémicycle 15 jours
d'insultes 15 jours d'invective c'est
les modélistes sont les modalités
d'expression la Présidence de
l'Assemblée nationale la présidente
elle-même le bureau ont décidé d'un
centre de mesure le gouvernement n'a pas
les commenter s'appelle la séparation
des pouvoirs il y a des recours nous
verrons ce que donne les recours mais
lorsqu'on
s'expose par son propre comportement
lorsqu'on Bafou le règlement de
l'assemblé lorsqu'on est présent et
qu'on ne siège que pour de l'invective
et mettre le bazar dans l'hémicycle il
ne faut pas s'étonner lorsque le
règlement est appliqué avec des
sanctions sont prises
c'est le cas c'est pas ma vision c'est
ce que nous voyons tous quotidiennement
avec une volonté de blocage avec une
volonté d'insultes avec une volonté
discrédit des institutions avec la
volonté finalement de renverser les
institutions dans lesquelles ils sont
fait élire donc ils sont hors du champ
républicains
justement qui a fait une grande
interview hier au Parisien Aujourd'hui
en France elle promet des moyens massifs
pour protéger les Français le 14 juillet
avec notamment l'interdiction de vote et
de vente et de transport de mortiers
est-ce que c'est le signe d'une réelle
inquiétude du gouvernement autour de ces
quatre vigilance d'une grande attention
la première mise l'a dit en prenant un
certain nombre de mesures et le ministre
de l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin et
mobilisé à 100% évidemment pour garantir
le fait que les choses se passent le
mieux possible nous savons que les nuits
du 13 du 14 juillet sont souvent des
nuits malheureusement où il se produit
des incidents il peut y avoir des feux
d'artifices
clandestins avec des mortiers qui n'ont
rien à faire là où ils sont il peut y
avoir parfois malheureusement des
incendies de voitures aussi et donc
puisque ce sont des nuits qui sont
parfois des nutentions ça nécessite
après les événements des derniers jours
encore plus de vigilance que les autres
années c'est tout le travail du
ministère de l'intérieur c'est tout le
travail des forces de police les mêmes
que les députés insoumis insultent en
participant à des manifestations comme
on a évoqué ça veut dire que la page des
émeutes n'est pas terminée pour vous il
faut être extrêmement vigilant le
président de la République l'a dit la
mobilisation des forces de sécurité a
permis de ramener le calme a permis de
rétablir l'ordre c'est une bonne chose
mais il faut être extrêmement clair il
faut être extrêmement attentif comme
tout le temps et c'est
la mobilisation des forces de sécurité
qui nous le permet une mobilisation dans
les petites villes aussi que vous
connaissez bien est-ce que ça vous
inquiète le fait que ça ne se soit pas
cantonné ou banlieue ou grande ville
la lecture de ce qui s'est passé
nécessite un peu de temps parce qu'on
regarde les choses avec un peu de
précision un peu de distance aussi et
qu'on essaye de comprendre d'abord ça
montre qu'il faut du temps pour bien
analyser bien bien
aucune violence est acceptable on l'a
dit aucune violence est acceptable n'est
excusable mais prenons peut-être un peu
de temps pour bien comprendre ce qui
s'est passé avant de nous précipiter sur
des explications toutes faites et vous
dites ça a eu des conséquences sur le
travail sur les commerces sur les
salariés est-ce que vous arrivez à les
mesurer aujourd'hui ces conseils au
cours d'évaluation parce que il y a
d'abord des choses qui sont très
différentes très inégales le ministre de
l'économie et la ministre des PME ont
annoncé un certain nombre de mesures
pour ma part pour ce concert le
ministère du travail nous avons indiqué
à nos services déconcentrés que les
commerces les entreprises qui du fait de
vandalisme d'incendie ne peuvent pas
fonctionner sont éligibles à l'activité
partielle et que les commerces et les
entreprises qui n'ont pas pu fonctionner
pendant quelques jours du fait de
couvre-feu d'arrêter d'arrêt des
transports en commun ou de mesures
prises par l'autoritaire administrative
c'est-à-dire par les préfets peuvent
aussi être éligibles à l'activité
partielle et combien on les recours à
cette activité nous sommes en train de
le mesurer parce que il y a une
particularité dans l'activité partielle
c'est qu'une entreprise qui subit un
préjudice de la nature que j'ai évoquée
avec les preuves nécessaires à un an ont
déclaré le préjudice lorsque vous mettez
vos vos vos cette chef d'entreprise et
que vous avez recours à l'activité
partielle vous avez droit jusqu'à un nom
la plupart des entreprises le font très
vite parce qu'elles ont besoin de
trésorerie elles ont besoin de d'aide
économiques mais ça prend toujours un
peu de temps pour le premier chiffre non
non pas encore Élisabeth borne dans
cette même interview elle est restée
très floue sur le calendrier d'un texte
que vous portez avec Gérald Darmanin
c'est le projet de loi immigration
est-ce que ce texte sera présenté au
mois de juillet maintenant nous l'avons
dit et la première ministre l'a dit dans
une autre interview nous nous ferons un
point à la rentrée il y a des
discussions notamment menées par le
ministre de l'Intérieur auquel je
participe aussi sur les différents
aspects l'aspect galliens l'aspect
travail pour essayer de trouver un
chemin trouver une voie de compromis
avec toutes celles et ceux qui le
souhaitent aujourd'hui les choses sont
encore un peu difficiles parce que nous
sommes très attachés les présidents des
groupes de la majorité l'ont dit très
attachés à ce que le texte soit global à
la fois avec un volet permettant de
d'affermir de consolider les décisions
de l'État son autorité mais aussi un
volet sur l'intégration par le travail
parce que nous considérons que le
travail et la maîtrise du français sont
les meilleurs outils
la première ministre a évoqué la
perspective du mois de novembre je crois
d'un débat au Parlement à l'automne mais
du coup la présentation Conseil des
ministres vous vous tapez sur la date
n'est pas fixée
nous avons dans les discussions et nous
verrons au fil des discussions en tout
cas il y aura rien en juillet les
discussions n'aboutiront pas à la fin
d'ici la fin du moisir dans les 15 jours
qui viennent alors il y a des
divergences la majorité sénatoriale et
les deux groupes LR l'ont dit ils ont
fait des propositions sans rien mettre
sur les questions du travail par exemple
ils ont aussi fait des propositions qui
s'affranchissent ou obligent à sortir du
cadre des traités européens ce qui n'est
pas la position de la majorité donc les
discussions vont se poursuivre il y a
dans les derniers jours des priorités un
peu différentes liées à l'actualité mais
prenons un peu de temps tout simplement
ça veut dire que c'est plus une priorité
aujourd'hui quand j'ai jamais une
priorité ça reste un besoin je crois sur
les deux aspects mais il faut trouver
une voie il faut trouver les moyens
d'avoir une majorité dans les deux
chambres à l'Assemblée au Sénat les
attentes ne sont pas forcément les mêmes
ce qui bloque notamment du côté des
républicains c'est la partie de votre ex
choisir les titres de séjour pour les
travailleurs dans les métiers en tension
les travailleurs étrangers qui exercent
dans les métiers en tension est-ce que
vous êtes prêts à reculer sur cette
partie pour trouver un compromis avec
nous avons dit que nous étions ouverts à
toutes les discussions notamment sur les
questions de critères permettant l'accès
à ces types de séjour mais de quoi
parlons-nous nous parlons d'un domaine
de femmes qui sont des étrangers non
communautaires puisque dès lors vous
êtes étrangers mais européen vous
bénéficiez d'une liberté de travail
d'une liberté de circulation donc on
parle d’étranger non communautaire qui
sont sur notre territoire depuis
longtemps dans le texte le premier texte
nous avions mis trois ans disons que
nous étions ouverts une discussion sur
ce délai là qui travaille de manière
légale c'est à dire qu'ils ont un
contrat de travail mais leur situation
personnelle est irrégulière souvent ce
sont des hommes et des femmes qui
avaient une carte de séjour et cette
carte de séjour n'a pas été renouvelée
parfois pour des raisons liées à leur
situation parfois pour des raisons plus
administratives de délais et donc ce que
nous disons c'est dès lors que vous
exercez dans un métier en tension nous
avons besoin de manœuvres nous avons
besoin de personnel que vous êtes là sur
le territoire depuis longtemps que vous
travaillez de manière légale il faut
sécuriser leur situation nous sommes
très loin de la question de l'appel
d'air donc nous sommes prêts à réfléchir
sur les critères
évoquait de la possibilité de 5 ans
plutôt que trois pourquoi pas mais
regardons cela la question n'est pas de
dire aujourd'hui ça je prends ça je ne
prends pas c'est un ensemble il y a un
ensemble texte ne s'arrêtent pas à une
seule mesure il y a un ensemble de
mesures et donc c'est une discussion
plus globale qu'il faut avoir mais
est-ce qu'un accord vous semble possible
vous discutez depuis des semaines il y a
toujours pas de texte nous le souhaitons
à chacun de prendre ses responsabilités
et de faire des concessions les
républicains aussi ils sont prêts à
quelle concession vous qui avec faudra
poser la question
vous êtes optimiste sur un accord je
l'espère toujours et nous nous battrons
pour l'avoir qu'est-ce que vous ferez
est-ce que vous passerez est-ce que vous
passerez quand même ce geste ou est-ce
que vous l'abandonnez vous voulez que je
réponde à des questions qui ne se pose
pas pas de politique fiction et chaque
chose en son temps
sur les syndicats que vous rencontrez
mercredi avec Elisabeth borde quel est
le menu de ses rencontres l'objectif
c'est d'abord de faire un point sur les
différentes discussions qui ont eu lieu
depuis des rencontres bilatérales
puisque avec la première ministre vont
rencontrer chacune des organisations
syndicales représentatives et chacune
des organisations patronales
représentatives pour entendre leur
priorités dans les semaines et les mois
qui viennent ils se sont vus entre eux
il y a eu un centre de réunion qui ne
sont pas des secrets des comptes-intures
de même été publiées dans la presse et
il y a eu des contacts et des échanges
entre mon cabinet le cabinet de la
Première ministre les organisations
syndicales j'ai eu moi-même des contacts
plus ou moins formels avec beaucoup
d'entre eux l'objectif est de pouvoir
voir ce qui est dans les mois qui
viennent peut définir un agenda social
qui soit le plus partagé possible
certains sujets sont portés par les
partenaires sociaux dans un cadre qu'on
peut qualifier d'autonomes avec ils
l'ont dit eux-mêmes des la volonté
d'avancer pour suivre un certain nombre
d'accord qu'ils ont passé pour avancer
et faire des diagnostics sur des
questions liées à la prévoyance pour
regarder comment ils peuvent améliorer
la gestion des groupes de protection
sociale
il y a des sujets sur lesquels le débat
et la négociation et sont évidemment
possibles entre eux mais qui relèvent de
ce qu'on appelle l'article L1 du Code du
travail je pense par exemple à l'emploi
du l'emploi des seniors ou encore les
parcours professionnels les
reconversions et tout ce qu'on peut
faire pour améliorer la prévention de
l'usure justement un mot sur l'emploi
des seniors parce que Bruno Le Maire
disait sur l'emploi des seniors il faut
arrêter le gâchis est-ce que vous allez
prendre de nouvelles mesures il faut
arrêter le gâcher parce que le plus
grand des gâchis c'est le gâchis des
compétences nous avons un taux d'emploi
des seniors qui a augmenté mais qui
reste très inférieure à la moyenne
européenne et nous avons un certain
nombre de dispositions certaines ont été
corrigés par la réforme des retraites
qui sont des incitations à sortir les
seigneurs du marché de l'emploi je
prends un exemple il a un peu technique
mais nous l'avons corrigé avec la
réforme des retraites il est plus
intéressant et il était plus intéressant
de proposer des ruptures
conventionnelles à des salariés à deux
ans ou deux ans et demi de la retraite
plutôt que de leur payer une indemnité
de retraite parce que le régime social
et fiscal de l'impur conventionnelle
était plus favorable c'est une inc à
sortir les seigneurs du marché de
l'emploi donc nous corrigeons un certain
nombre de choses
que être toquées est-ce que vous allez
rediscuter de l'index senior par exemple
deux mesures qui étaient dans la réforme
des retraites donc Conseil
constitutionnel est considérer que ce
n'était pas leur place sans se prononcer
sur le fond c'est le CDI pour les
demandeurs d'emploi Seigneur proposé par
les sénateurs c'est l'index senior il y
a d'autres mesures qui sont possibles
vous allez les remettre sur et je vais
vous répondre il y a d'autres mesures
possibles il faut par exemple
accompagner la reprise d'emploi des
seniors qui ont perdu leur peut-être par
des incitations il y a des questions
relatives à la reconversion reclassement
à l'accès à la formation tout cela y
compris les mesures qui ont été
retoquées par le Conseil constitutionnel
peut-être discuter par les partenaires
sociaux nous allons voir avec eux
justement dans cette réunion comment
est-ce qu'on procède est-ce qu'il
considère que cette question de l'emploi
des seigneurs est la première des
priorités dans ce cas là il faut qu'on
puisse mettre le cadre mettre en place
le cadre de discussion très vite est-ce
qu'il considère que cette discussion
doit commencer après d'autres il y a des
discussions qui relèvent de leur
initiative de leurs compétences je
notamment en règle sur l'agir Carco le
régime complémentaire de retraite il y a
des sujets que nous devons aborder eux
et nous parce que en matière d'assurance
chômage les règles sont fixées jusqu'au
31 décembre 2023 et au-delà du 31
décembre dans le cadre des lois telles
qu'elles ont été votées il faut que les
partenaires sociaux se saisissent à
nouveau de ce sujet là et donc nous
allons essayer de poser ça ne veut pas
dire trouver des points d'accord sur le
fond mais voir quels sont les sujets qui
sont prioritaires à quelle échéance ils
sont abordés avec quelle méthode est-ce
que vous souhaitez que ce CDI seniors et
l'index seniors rentrent en vigueur je
souhaite qu'il soit au menu des
discussions des partenaires sociaux et
si les partenaires sociaux considèrent
que sont de bonnes mesures et s'ils
aboutissent un accord parce que il y a
plusieurs étapes interprofessionnelles
le président de la République la
première Miss moi-même avons dit que
s'il y avait un accord dans ce cadre là
et sur ces sujets là nous ferions comme
sur la question du partage de la valeur
c'est-à-dire une transposition de
l'accord intégralement et fidèlement il
y a trois têtes nouvelles chez les
partenaires sociaux mais def à la CGT à
la CFDT est-ce que c'est une chance je
ne sais pas si c'est une chance parce
que ce n'est pas au gouvernement de
choisir ses interlocuteurs c'est le
fruit de résultat c'est le fruit de
résultat
et de congrès chacun vient avec sa
personnalité soit fibiné pour la CGT
Marylise à la CFDT Patrick Martin qui a
une grande qualité à mes yeux c'est
qu'il est ronalpin donc nous avons ces
origines géographiques
parce qu'il a été responsabilité dans ma
région parce qu'il est numéro 2 de
Geoffroy de route des yeux depuis
longtemps et que nous avons l'habitude
de nous voir c'est un choix des
partenaires sociaux oui le maire a
raison ça apporte un nouveau regard ça
apporte une forme de renouvellement
c'est le principe même ça ne change pas
les positions de fond des organisations
et c'est ce sont ces positions qui à mes
yeux sont les plus importantes au-delà
des questions de personnes le Sénat
entame aujourd'hui l'examen du projet de
loi pour le plein emploi est-ce que vous
pensez toujours obtenir le plein emploi
en 2027 parce qu'il y a Bruno Le Maire
il avait l'air assez pessimiste sur les
prévisions de croissance c'est
l'objectif il y a des prévisions de
croissance qui sont impactées qui sont
touchés par les questions liées à
l'inflation l'énergie à l'instabilité
géopolitique nous continuons à avancer
2027 je crois je le crois je crois qu'il
faut redoubler d'efforts au premier
trimestre 2023 notre économie a créé
plus de 80 000 emplois nets et par
ailleurs l'emploi que nous créons
c'était 50 000 au 4e trimestre 2023 donc
créer un million 800 000 emplois depuis
l'économie a créé un million 800 000
emplois depuis 2017 et nous nous
rapprochons du plein emploi et des 5%.
et il y a un point qui est intéressant
et important c'est que lorsqu'on regarde
les indicateurs sur la qualité de
l'emploi et de la nature des emplois
créés pour la première fois depuis une
vingtaine d'années en 2022 et ça se
poursuit au premier trimestre 2023 52%
c'est-à-dire plus de la moitié ça
n'était pas arrivé depuis des années des
années 52% des nouveaux contrastes sont
des CDI ça signifie qu'on crée de
l'emploi et qu'en plus cet emploi n'est
pas de l'emploi précaire comme on
l'entend souvent mais plutôt un emploi
qui s'améliore en termes de stabilité et
de durée des contrats c'est l'effet des
réformes que nous avons menées notamment
sur le bonus malus c'est l'effet des
tensions de recrutement qui incite aussi
les employeurs proposer plus de CDI et
c'est une amélioration de la qualité
d'emploi dont chacun peut satisfaire la
principale mesure de sexe c'est la
création du réseau France travail c'est
pour mieux coordonner les acteurs du
service public de l'emploi et permettre
aux demandeurs d'employés aux
allocataires de n'avoir qu'un
interlocuteur une porte d'entrée
possible effectivement les sénateurs ils
veulent pas que Pôle emploi soit
rebaptisé est-ce que vous allez bien un
réseau France travail qui va réunir tous
les acteurs de l'emploi et mieux les
coordonnées c'est aujourd'hui Pôle
Emploi ce sont les missions locales Cap
Emploi pour les personnes en situation
de handicap les sénateurs aux
commissions à ajouter les maisons de
l'emploi les Plans Locaux d'insertion
par l'économie l'emploi ce qui est une
bonne chose donc ça c'est le réseau
France travail et nous nous pensons que
l'opérateur principal celui qui est le
plus connu aujourd'hui celui qui va être
en charge de la production des des
référentiels des systèmes d'information
parce que ce serait technique mais c'est
le nerf de la guerre donc Pôle Emploi
gagnerait gagne à transformer et à
changer de vie aussi de nom pour que ce
soit plus visible et de venir France
travail les sénateurs disent le réseau
s'appelle France travail l'opérateur va
s'appeler France travail il y a un
risque de nous ne partageons pas ce
point de vue nous avons trois jours de
débats devant nous je pense que les
travaux qui ont été faits en commission
par les sénateurs de la commission des
affaires sociales sont les travaux de
bonne qualité il y a quelques points sur
lesquels nous avons des désaccords et
c'est normal ça s'appelle le débat
parlementaire je vais défendre le point
de vue du gouvernement devant le Sénat à
partir de cet après-midi et puis nous
allons continuer le texte sera adopté à
l'Assemblée nationale examiné pardon à
l'Assemblée nationale à l'automne il y
aura une commission mixte paritaire
cherche dans son temps mais je suis
convaincu que nous pouvons trouver à la
fois sur la question de l'organisation
et de l'amélioration du service public
de l'emploi autour du réseau et de ce
projet France travail sur la question de
l'accompagnement des allocataires du RSA
avec cet objectif de 15 ans et sur
l'emploi des personnes en situation de
handicap on peut trouver de on peut
trouver beaucoup plus de convergence que
différence on va parler du RSA mais sur
France travail il y a un autre sujet
d'inquiétude c'est la place des
collectivités
le Sénat veut fait en sorte que les
collectivités conservent leurs
problématiques par exemple région de
France dénonce un projet
recentralisateur il faut nous dire en
quoi il n'y a au bonnes disposition il
n'y a pas une virgule dans le texte pas
une qui modifie les compétences des
collectivités locales ni la répartition
entre l'État et les collectivités ni la
répartition entre les collectivités
entre elles pas une ligne donc je veux
bien qu'on nous dise que ces
recentralisateurs mais il faut nous dire
pourquoi et d'ailleurs il y a 13 régions
en métropole et sur les 13 régions nous
en avons 6 qui ont soit signé soit voté
pour avec l'État avec le gouvernement
pour mettre en place des protocoles de
préfiguration de France travail en
parallèle au débat parlementaire c'est
la preuve que ça ne va pas si mal dans
les relations avec chacune des régions
sur ce sujet là de la même manière je
sais qu'il y avait des inquiétudes sur
les missions locales les missions
locales restent les missions locales
elles gardent leur statut et elle
continueront à être financer par l'État
et non pas par l'opérateur qui s'appelle
Pôle emploi au France travail donc nous
allons le faire les collectivités nous
leur donnons plus de place Pascal
siègeront toutes au Comité National
est-ce siègeront au comité régional avec
un pilotage et ta région comme des
départementales avec un pilotage état
département et puis nous voulons un
comité France travail par bassin
d'emploi et la grande nouveauté pour les
collectivités séquence dans ces comités
France travail elles vont participer à
définir les priorités de la politique de
l'emploi priorité que l'opérateur
aujourd'hui Pôle Emploi peut-être demain
France travaille sera chargé de mettre
en œuvre donc nous leur donnons une
place dans la définition des priorités
du service public de l'emploi c'est
plutôt une amélioration qu'un retrait
l'autre question l'autre partie de ce
texte est la question du RSA vous
souhaitez une contrepartie dans une
logique de droit et de devoirs c'est ce
que vous dites et donc 15 à 20h
d'activités hebdomadaires pour les
allocataires sauf que c'est pas inscrit
dans la loi les sénateurs veulent que ce
soit inscrit finalement ils sont un
manque de courage politique n'aime pas
l'inscrire sur blanc d'abord ce que nous
voulons effectivement c'est revenir à
l'esprit du RMI en 1988 quand le RMI a
été créé c'était considéré à juste titre
comme un revenu de subsistance personne
n'est riche au RSA accompagné d'une
logique d'insertion et d'un contrat
d'engagement que nous voulons rénover
parce qu'aujourd'hui moins de la moitié
des allocataires se voit proposer un
contrat d'engagement réciproque et donc
il faut réinvestir sur l'accompagnement
parce que la meilleure des choses à
faire quand on parle des allocataires du
RSA c'est de considérer que la vraie
solidarité c'est de les sortir du RSA
des aider en sortir et nous ne sommes
pas quittes de notre devoir solidarité
quand nous avons versé 607 euros à un
homme ou une femme sans revenu nous en
sommes nous en sommes quitte lorsqu'on
l'aider à sortir du RSA nous avons écrit
dans la loi que ce contrat d'engagement
réciproque doit tenir compte de l'âge du
niveau de formation de l'endroit où on
vit des freins des freins c'est est-ce
que vous avez une voiture est-ce que
vous avez une possibilité de déplacement
est-ce que vous avez des enfants et une
possibilité de garde d'enfant et
sénateurs souhaitent que ces 15 20h que
là les 15 heures soit inscrits comme un
minimum
je comprends la démarche mais j'ai deux
interrogations que je partagerai avec le
Sénat la première c'est que nous savons
qu'un certain nombre locataires du RSA
sont trop éloignés de l'emploi et
malheureusement une vie tellement qui a
bossé que 15 heures d'entrée comme ça
c'est trop compliqué et il faut être
certainement plus progressif c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'à l'article 6 du
projet de loi nous avons prévu que
pour certains les plus en difficulté et
puisse y avoir un accompagnement social
avant d'envisager l'accompagnement
professionnel la deuxième difficulté la
deuxième interrogation c'est que nous
sommes dans une mise en place
progressive 15 20h d'activités il faut
pouvoir faire en sorte qu'elle soit
adaptée personnalisée partout sur les
territoires aujourd'hui songer qu'il y a
un allocataire sur 5 presque un allocat
sur 5 18% qui n'a aucun suivi mais du
coup est-ce que vous êtes quand même à
réfléchir là
c'est 1 sur 3 je suis prêt à travailler
avec les sénateurs pour trouver une
formulation qui permettent à la fois de
respecter leur volonté parce que je la
partage et que l'objectif du
gouvernement c'est que le maximum est en
vérité tous les allocataires puissent
accéder à 15 un acteur 15 amateurs
d'activités d'insertion d'accompagnement
tout en veillant à ce que pour celles et
ceux pour lesquelles ça ne sera pas
possible parce que nous avons des hommes
et des femmes qui sont très abîmées par
la vie très cabossée et qu'il faut
respecter il puisse y avoir des
possibilités des rogatoires de manière à
ce que ce soit progressif beaucoup de
sénateurs sont ont été élus locaux si
ils ont des départements on siégé dans
des commissions qui instruisent les
questions relatives au RSA ils savent
cette réalité un dernier mot sur le RSA
est-ce qu'il faut le suspendre pour les
parents de mineurs délinquants comme le
demande les républicains je ne suis pas
persuadé que la suspension du RSA soit
une solution à un problème de
parentalité il y a d'autres motifs je
pense que les parents de très jeune
mineur on a vu dans les derniers
incidents des mineurs de 11 12 13 14 ans
doivent être mis face à leur
responsabilité je crois plus je crois
plus à la contravention je crois plus
aux dédommagement qu'à la suspension
d'un minimum de subsistance parce que
parfois vous savez il y a des fratries
il y a des frères et sœurs qui n'ont pas
toujours
les mêmes qui n'ont pas fait les qui
n'ont pas commis les mêmes actes que un
grand frère ou un petit frère qui aurait
fait une énorme bêtise et même combien
de délits et qui mériterait sanctions un
dernier mot niveau du socle il y a des
rumeurs de remaniement qui se font de
plus en plus insistantes est-ce que vous
êtes inquiet il y a des rumeurs et donc
les rumeurs ça ne se commande pas et
l'essentiel c'est d'être au travail tout
ça n'appartient au président de la
République pas d'inquiétude de votre
côté la question n'est pas là c'est
appartient au seul président de la
République et on suivra bien sûr
l'examen du projet de loi pour le plein
emploi ce sera à partir de cet
après-midi dans l'hémicycle du Sénat
merci beaucoup merci Olivier du sable
d'avoir été notre invité on passe au
club des territoires